la frontière qui sépare la raison de la
folie et fine les pandémiques à toutes
les cultures
je m'appelle Terry j'adore vos yeux
docteur Michaels oui inspecteur boy de
la brigade criminelle deux enfants sont
morts dépecs comme des cochons
vous savez ce que signifie ces
inscriptions ici je prends le pouvoir
ici je deviens le pouvoir
nom de Dieu
je te rituel effectué sur demande des
gens qui paient pour bénéficier du multi
recherche le pouvoir
j'en veux une avec un beau regard pour
lui c'est un gang bang comme un autre
si deux jeunes victimes c'était juste
pour se préparer
les enfants ont disparu à travers
l'Europe une douzaine en Espagne
il fait la même chose ici
est-ce que vous savez la France c'est
notre homme viens on y va
j'aimerais juste connaître son visage
pour l'instant je ne vois connaître
monstrueux faites attention il pourrait
s'en prendre à vous
on a deux agents blessés